good morning John I know I'm too late I
don't know what I'm thinking I'm on the
wrong side of the bell curve I'm
catching the wave as it crashes but I
simply cannot help myself
Oh
my phone
stop you right there so now are you
right
I'm stuck I guess I'm a little bit of an
Internet dance craze hipster it turns
out I mean yeah it's great Harlem shake
but don't forget about get on people its
feelings might get hurt and numa numa
come on right because I can't help but
not think too much about everything I am
really curious as to why internet dance
craze videos often seem to be bilingual
English and Spanish English and Japanese
English in Korean English and Moldovan
English and Soulja Boy of course it is
important to note that this trend
predates internet culture and also it is
still completely possible in the
Internet age to have a dance craze based
on a unilingual song but it is
definitely a majority and it is
definitely a trend and I definitely
don't know why it is though I have some
little guesses but they're not good
enough for the light of day I don't
think so ideas comments hell right
enough of that you people are probably
waiting for me to talk about something
else I'm kind of avoiding it cuz it's
freaking me out it has been a big week
in John you my brother John got to
interview the president bit which was
cool here's a highlight almost all
economists agree that we should stop
minting pennies it's a really obvious
thing it's not a particularly
interesting or partisan thing but it's
really obvious so my question to you is
why haven't we done it you know I got to
tell you John I don't know it's one of
those things where I think people get
attached emotionally to the way things
have been John Green you stumped the
president pretty cool and in addition to
that the brain scoop was featured on NPR
if he waiter in Chicago got to make a
video with Matt Damon who you may or may
not know is my idol Lizzie Bennet
diaries one two streamys these are the
pre awards we may still yet win more and
we launched crash course chemistry which
I'm very excited about and I got back
from United Kingdom so I don't really
know what time it is and oh yeah
also the president refused to name your
unborn child if I gave a preference and
you guys went the other way forever this
child would say the president doesn't
like my name the main thing is tell tell
either Eleanor or Alice not
forget to be awesome what hi